so of course everyone is so excited that
part two
is going to drop on netflix in may
[Applause]
what are we gonna see in season two are
we gonna see her
soaring to new heights is it going to be
a lot of family conflict are we going to
see relationship conflict
a little bit of everything how about how
about if i just say that that covers the
whole spectrum of it
i know what you're fishing for dj you're
good you're good
but i'm a vessel for the fans and they
just want to know i know
this is coming into the to the part
where selena and chris
you know are elope and they get married
and all of that is covered yes of course
i mean
it would not be a star our story
if we eliminated that that's part of you
know
our life well i know that i know that
there's a lot of
difficult things that you probably don't
want to have to revisit was it emotional
for you
getting through season two most
definitely yeah
yeah it's it's not a walk at the park
that's for sure
she's not here you know and we all know
this and
it's just a little bit of everything it
makes you feel happy and
you know there's some sad moments and
then there's some moments that
personally i don't want to revisit you
know and it
and it brings up some really weird
feelings inside so it's just a little
bit of everything to be honest with the
others
[Music]
of the series part one it debuted in
december
and holy moly the reception
was huge what is your reaction to seeing
such success with the series you
executive produced
i guess what i'm most proud of is the
fact that
there is a a life story or
of a series of a mexican-american family
on netflix how insane is that
daedra it shouldn't be it should be all
the time but
i don't think that people people truly
understand
the magnitude of just that alone i'm
very proud i know that
coming into this and making the decision
of doing this
series was to be able to show everyone
that
there was more than just the movie the
movie was just a fast pace of you know
you only have two hours and 10 minutes i
believe to
you know show the world basically selena
and lozino's in our band and okay you
know
everything that her falling in love and
then ultimately her are losing her life
and so we had the opportunity to be able
to do something where
you know a lot of people would ask like
why this and how how did y'all do this
and how did you do that and
so that kind of um was one of the main
factors a lot of things that a lot of
people don't know
you know i know that a lot of people you
know
have opinions you know and i know that
not everybody is going to like it
100 people are going to love it some
people aren't and that's okay
you know i i don't take any any offense
to that at all i get it but
overall it did amazing what has the
feedback been like that you've seen what
have you been hearing about
part one of the series on social media
yeah you know you have you have people
that leave their straight up honest
opinion like i didn't like it i don't
think she looked exactly like selena
you know nobody's gonna look like celine
i mean we had the same kickback
actually um deidre when jennifer played
selena
because people were upset at the fact
that jennifer lopez was playing salinas
she's a puerto rican why is a puerto
rican playing a mexican
that blew my mind completely i just
didn't understand that as like
we should all be supporting this because
she
is a latina and it happened also with
christians she doesn't look like her
she's too flakka she's not
dark enough she's like this she's like
that and you know um there is only one
selena she
unfortunately is no longer with us and
this is somebody that is
telling the story and she's she's not
celine and
jennifer wasn't selena either and i
think christian did a great job
i think the whole cast did an amazing
job have you had a chance to speak with
christian since the series has come out
we did we've talked a little bit here
and there i asked her i said
hey so like i know you knew taking on
this role
was gonna come with some harsh harshness
you know you know people are gonna
come at you and um she said i said did
you ever
not want to do it or did you how did you
decide and she said no that she just
felt that you know um she could handle
it and
i think she's done a great job you know
i got to know her a little bit and you
know she's very delicate and small and
everything but she's got that latina in
her
she's got that bite in her and i and i
love it and i'm
i'm really proud of her and i know that
she knew that she was
stepping in some into some difficult
shoes
to fill but i think she did great we're
all about
um making the american dream um
to better our lives for our families and
that's exactly what we were doing